Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
"Freud face au malaise
des civilisations".
Freud naquit au mitan
du 19e siècle à Freiberg
et il s'éteignit
le 23 septembre 1939 à Londres,
après un exil forcé de Vienne,
le 4 juin 1938,
pour échapper à la barbarie nazie.
Homme des Lumières,
il est le fondateur
de la psychanalyse,
une nouvelle science émanant
de la vie d'âme de ses contemporains
au travers de leurs vicissitudes
temporelles et intemporelles.
On a souvent réduit
la psychanalyse
à la science des rêves,
ce qu'elle est,
mais le décryptage freudien
s'étend jusqu'au malaise
des civilisations
en abordant les besoins aussi divers
que la sexualité, la religion,
les relations sociales
et familiales
et des questions politiques,
notamment la guerre
ou le nationalisme.
Le savant viennois s'interrogea,
je le cite :
"Pourquoi les individus peuples
se méprisent-ils,
"se haïssent-ils
les uns les autres,
"comme si, dès lors
qu'on réunit une multitude,
"toutes les acquisitions morales
s'effaçaient
"pour ne laisser place
qu'aux traumatismes
"et aux pulsions ?"
Cette énigme non résolue va être
l'objet de notre débat.
Nous allons chercher
à comprendre, en nous adossant
à l'oeuvre de Freud,
les raisons qui poussent
les hommes et les femmes
à s'entretuer dans une pulsion
d'agression ininterrompue,
et les civilisations,
à s'entredéchirer
dans cette conflictualité sans fin
du monde.
Pour en parler,
je vous présente
mes invités. Jean-Pierre Le Goff,
vous êtes philosophe,
sociologue et essayiste.
Gérard Miller, vous êtes
psychanalyste et essayiste.
Juliette Méadel,
vous êtes ancienne ministre,
haut fonctionnaire.
J-L. Chassaing,
vous êtes psychiatre
et psychanalyste.
Pierre de Senarclens,
vous êtes politologue,
professeur émérite
de l'université de Lausanne.
Est-ce que cette prévision
pessimiste de Freud
sur la domination exterminatrice
des forces de la nature,
extraite de son ouvrage
"Malaise dans la civilisation",
ou selon la traduction,
"Malaise
"dans la culture",
vous paraît-elle d'actualité ?
Jean-Pierre Le Goff ?
-Oui, elle me paraît
totalement d'actualité.
Je dirais surtout
après une période assez angélique,
c'est-à-dire si on remonte un peu
sur un demi-siècle, on va dire,
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
il y avait les souvenirs
de la Shoah,
mais très vite est apparu
un autre type de société,
la société de consommation
et de loisirs,
avec une forme d'hédonisme
assez nouvelle,
mais si on va
beaucoup plus loin encore,
il y a eu
la chute du mur de Berlin,
la façon dont
la construction européenne
a été lancée
et je pense qu'il y a eu
une espèce d'angélisme,
l'utopie
d'une espèce de fin de l'histoire
et du tragique qui est inhérent
à l'histoire qui s'est développée
à ce moment-là,
avec l'idée que finalement,
les hommes pouvaient s'entendre
sans qu'il y ait
une part d'agressivité,
avec l'idée de la fin des guerres,
c'est-à-dire le doux commerce,
le libéralisme,
le néolibéralisme,
plus les droits de l'homme.
C'était la fin de l'histoire...
On pensait que le monde allait
vers ce mouvement. Il s'est trouvé
que ça a été assez vite démenti.
Il y a eu la guerre du Kosovo,
de la Serbie, en Europe,
qui est revenue directement,
qui a remontré le tragique.
Il y a eu aussi le Covid,
d'une certaine façon,
par rapport à cette euphorie.
Tout d'un coup,
on retrouve le tragique
et la mort possible. Et alors,
aujourd'hui,
vous avez les guerres
en Europe avec Poutine,
plus les risques de guerre.
Donc tout ça s'est un peu effondré
et le terrorisme islamiste
avait quelque chose
qui m'a beaucoup frappé,
c'est la difficulté à assumer
le fait qu'il peut y avoir
en face de nous des ennemis
qui veulent nous détruire.
Sans reprendre Freund,
que vous le vouliez ou non,
vous avez des ennemis.
Même en disant "J'en veux pas",
ils viennent vous chercher.
Quand je voyais, par exemple,
les manifestations
contre les attentats
de Charlie Hebdo,
j'avais été frappé par des espèces
de nouveaux rituels de deuil
avec des bougies, des ballons
et un certain type de chant
qu'on mettait souvent en avant,
John Lennon.
"Imagine un monde enfin pacifié."
Pas "L'ennemi connaîtra
le prix du sang et des larmes",
Chant des partisans.
L'inverse. Il y a eu une difficulté.
Aujourd'hui,
on progresse à affronter
cette réalité, c'est-à-dire une part
d'agressivité qui est indestructible
au sein de l'être humain,
pour reprendre la formule.
C'est difficile.
Si vous regardez le cheminement,
on y arrive
avec des points de fuite.
-Alors,
cette vérité freudienne,
intemporelle, vous la partagez,
Gérard Miller ?
-"Malaise dans la civilisation",
"Malaise dans la culture",
c'est 1929,
c'est la crise économique,
c'est la montée de plus
en plus nette au pouvoir des nazis.
On peut se dire : "On comprend
pourquoi, tout particulièrement
"à ce moment-là,
Freud était pessimiste"
et pourquoi il dit : "Moi-même,
qui ai plus de 70 ans,
"c'est à mes petits-enfants
que je pense,
"parce que pour moi,
évidemment,
"tout est déjà foutu."
Il faut dire que contrairement
à ce qu'on a évoqué,
je n'ai jamais cru,
freudien,
à la fin de l'histoire,
qui a été un moment court
dans l'idéologie,
venue des Etats-Unis,
parce que ma génération
a connu la guerre du Vietnam
et ensuite, toute une série
de catastrophes.
Même la pauvreté et la misère
en France m'ont permis de croire
que de toute façon, en effet,
le pessimisme freudien
était intemporel,
mais je pense
que ce qu'on va essayer
d'expliquer, justement,
c'est pourquoi,
d'une certaine façon,
quand on est freudien,
on ne peut qu'être pessimiste
sur le long terme.
Au court terme,
essayons d'être heureux,
d'élever nos enfants avec bonheur.
Mais sur le long terme,
quand on est freudien,
on ne peut être que pessimiste.
-Juliette Méadel ?
-Je serai moins pessimiste que vous,
non pas sur l'avenir,
mais sur le passé, parce qu'au fond,
s'il y a quelque chose
que nous ont appris
ces 25 dernières années,
c'est qu'on a cherché à domestiquer
ces pulsions d'agressivité.
Je suis toujours assez frappée
quand on dit :
"C'était mieux avant,
c'était plus apaisé."
Par exemple,
pour parler de la violence
en débat politique, on dit :
"Avant, c'était apaisé,
ce qui est faux. On voit,
à la fin du 19e, des caricatures
d'une agressivité inouïe.
Au fond, cette violence
qu'on déplore aujourd'hui,
était bien pire.
-Ca veut dire que la culture
n'a pas corrigé la chose.
-Ca veut dire
que la culture a corrigé la chose
et que la violence est
de plus en plus mal vécue,
parce qu'on est de plus en plus
intolérants à la violence
et à l'agressivité.
C'est en ça
que je suis plus optimiste.
-Jean-Louis Chassaing,
la violence était là hier,
est là aujourd'hui.
La vérité freudienne
est intemporelle
et permanente ?
-Alors, déjà, parler de pessimisme
ou d'optimisme,
c'est très,
très à l'heure du temps.
Enfin, c'est-à-dire,
effectivement,
il s'agit de mettre un peu d'affect,
alors que les textes de Freud
et des continuateurs de Freud
sont plutôt des textes qui essaient
d'avoir un raisonnement,
plus que des troubles
de l'humeur,
pour reprendre
les choses d'aujourd'hui.
C'est intéressant de...
Moi, je ne parlerai pas
de pessimisme ou d'optimisme.
J'essaye de lire Freud et Lacan
d'une manière plus logique
que d'une manière
où on met de l'humeur.
Mais je trouve que...
Bon, quel est ce malaise ?
Et est-ce qu'il est encore actuel ?
Freud y va très fort,
au début de son texte.
Je veux dire
qu'il y a trois occasions
d'être mal,
c'est-à-dire avec son corps,
avec le monde extérieur
et dans la relation à l'autre.
Et c'est effectivement
ce dernier point que Freud
va étudier, puisque,
c'est l'autre chose
que j'aimerais dire,
c'est que Freud
n'est pas sociologue
et il a écrit un texte,
je crois, en 1932,
sur la weltanschauung,
c'est-à-dire comme quoi
la psychanalyse n'est pas
une vision du monde.
Et donc, je pense
que cette vision du monde comme ça
n'est pas possible
pour la psychanalyse.
On sait par rapport...
-Oui, mais quand il dit
que dès qu'il y a
une multitude,
les gens s'entretuent,
c'est quand même
une vision du monde...
-Non. L'autre...
L'autre point,
c'est aussi sa spécificité.
Et dans ses textes,
il parle toujours,
et assez souvent d'ailleurs,
d'une similitude
entre l'individuel et le collectif.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a toujours
un aller-retour
entre les deux. C'est pas seulement
parler du collectif,
mais le collectif,
c'est aussi le sujet individuel.
-On va rentrer dans le détail.
Votre point de vue,
Pierre de Senarclens ?
Vous enseignez
les sciences politiques.
Est-ce que vous pensez
que Freud est
un éclaireur politique
des crises ?
-Il est dans tous les cas
un éclaireur politique
et il rejoint, disons, une tradition
de la politique internationale
qui associe effectivement
l'humanité à l'agression.
De ce point de vue-là,
Freud énonce des postulats
qui sont assumés largement
dans la politique
internationale,
mais Freud établit un lien
entre le processus civilisateur
et la limitation
de l'agressivité
et il montre que cette limite
de ce processus civilisateur
entraîne un malaise.
Aujourd'hui,
nous devons vivre
avec un malaise qui est différent
de celui qu'il avait mis en avant,
mais qui n'en reste pas moins
un malaise important
face aux contraintes
de civilisation.
Et pour revenir
à ce qui a été dit
sur, disons,
l'immédiat après-guerre,
ce qui a dominé cet après-guerre,
tout de même,
c'est un haut degré
d'institutionnalisation
de la politique internationale,
pas que par les organisations
internationales,
mais aussi par l'équilibre
de la terreur, n'est-ce pas,
qui créait quand même
quelque chose
qu'il était difficile
de modifier
dans cet équilibre.
Et la fin de l'histoire,
c'était l'idée
qu'ayant cette confrontation
de la Guerre froide terminée,
on allait
pouvoir enfin réaliser ensemble
ce processus de civilisation.
-Gérard Miller, là-dessus ?
-Je sens que dans cette émission,
je vais désespérer ma voisine,
madame la ministre, parce que...
-Souvent,
dans des émissions communes,
vous me désespérez.
-Parce que...
c'est le moment de dire,
presque de corriger
ce que vous avez dit au début,
que non seulement
quand la multitude est là,
il y a en effet
du meurtre dans l'air,
même lorsqu'il n'y en a que deux.
Il faut rappeler
que le début de l'histoire
dans la Bible...
-Pas dans cette émission.
-Non, certainement pas.
Lorsque l'histoire commence,
après Adam et Eve,
c'est les deux frères
qui s'entretuent,
Abel et Caïn.
Dès qu'il y en a deux,
c'est ce que la psychanalyse
met en avant...
-Permettez-moi juste
de vous interrompre, là.
Comment vous expliquez,
dans ce cas-là,
que nonobstant tous les progrès,
la civilisation humaine
dans les pays démocratiques
n'arrive pas à venir à bout
de la pulsion d'agression
que certains considèrent
comme une décivilisation,
voire même un ensauvagement ?
-Je vais répondre à votre question
de façon très claire.
Quelle est la grande découverte
de Freud ?
La grande découverte de Freud,
c'est que nous ne voulons pas
notre bien.
Si nous interrogeons
tout un chacun,
chacun peut avoir l'idée
qu'il souhaite être heureux,
comme un coq en pâte. Pas du tout,
dit Freud. Il y a quelque chose
qui nous fait travailler
contre nous-mêmes.
C'est ça, la pulsion de mort.
C'est pas le fait de vouloir
détruire l'autre,
c'est une pulsion
contre nous-mêmes.
Cette découverte, notamment,
qu'il découvre dans
"Au-delà du principe du plaisir",
qu'il y a quelque chose de plus fort
que la recherche du plaisir,
la recherche de l'homéostase...
C'est ça.
Nous, au contraire, êtres humains,
nous voulons la crise,
pas seulement l'agressivité,
la mort de l'autre,
nous voulons
quelque chose qui nous détruit.
C'est en ce sens,
madame, que nous sommes
pessimistes. Je garde le terme.
Nous sommes pessimistes,
parce qu'il y a quelque chose
qui nous fait travailler
contre nous-mêmes.
-Juliette Méadel.
-Que la grande découverte de Freud
soit que nous ayons en nous-mêmes
une pulsion de mort
ou d'autodestruction
qui cohabite avec le désir de vivre
et être heureux, c'est une évidence.
Ce que je trouve plus intéressant
dans la question que vous posez,
c'est la question du collectif.
La question,
plus politiquement, c'est :
"Est-ce que collectivement,
"nous en sommes arrivés
à un stade de développement
"de notre société",
j'aime pas dire "civilisation",
"qui est à un stade
d'autodestruction ?"
C'est ça, à mon sens,
la grande question qui est posée
par la raréfaction
des ressources naturelles
et par un capitalisme
qui devient fou.
Et ce qui, à mon avis, le coeur,
et votre émission...
-La violence est encore plus grande
dans les pays totalitaires.
Ils n'ont pas le capitalisme comme
substrat politique.
-Autre chose.
Les pays totalitaires
dont vous parlez,
dont on entend de plus en plus
la voix aujourd'hui,
qui semblent se liguer ensemble,
je parle de la Chine,
de la Russie,
contre un autre modèle,
un contre-modèle, le nôtre,
qui est un modèle certes capitaliste
avec ses dévoiements.
Ces deux modèles-là,
ça fait un choc,
dont chacun d'entre eux
cherche à détruire l'autre
et qui porte aussi en lui-même
sa propre destruction. C'est ça,
le tournant que nous allons vivre
dans les années qui viennent.
C'est moins
une pulsion individuelle
d'autodestruction qui,
évidemment,
vous l'avez dit,
est inhérente à l'homme,
qu'une pulsion collective.
C'est intéressant.
-Jean-Pierre,
je voudrais que vous précisiez
quelque chose, parce que le point
de vue analytique, c'est qu'il y a
une pulsion d'autodestruction
chez l'individu.
Ca a été souligné
par Gérard Miller
et Jean-Louis Chassaing.
Mais est-ce qu'il y a
une distinction
qu'on peut faire
entre Freud et Aron ?
Parce qu'Aron dit :
"L'homme est raisonnable.
Les hommes le sont-ils ?" Alors,
est-ce que c'est la multitude
qui vient aiguiser
la pulsion d'agression
ou est-ce que
cette pulsion d'agression est
originaire dans la personne ?
-Moi, je pense
qu'elle est originaire.
Ca veut pas dire que la multitude...
ne l'accroit pas. Quant à Aron,
il y a une vision de l'histoire
qui reste tragique, chez Aron.
L'histoire est ouverte
sur des possibles,
y compris totalitaires,
puisque c'est quand même quelqu'un
qui a lutté
contre le totalitarisme,
mais ce qu'il s'agit
à mon avis, de comprendre,
je pense, c'est Steiner,
un critique littéraire
qui disait :
"Nous avons appris via la guerre
que les bibliothèques,
"les oeuvres d'art peuvent coexister
à côté des camps de concentration
"dans une société allemande
qui a créé
"des musiques formidables,
"des arts, etc."
-Il y a même un film
qui montre
que le gardien d'Auschwitz
ne se rendait pas compte,
apparemment, de ce qui
se passait dans le camp
de concentration.
-Oui,
avec une idéologie d'enfermement.
On peut essayer de mettre de côté,
mais je pense que...
Je vais poser
une question plus générale :
"Y a-t-il une progression
dans la morale ?"
"Peut-on penser
la progression morale comme
"on pense le développement
économicosocial du bien-être ?"
Je ne le crois pas.
Je crois
qu'il y a... L'apport de Freud,
je ne suis pas psychanalyste,
c'est ça, c'est qu'il y a
quelque chose d'irréductible.
Ca veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
essayer de le combattre,
mais il faut savoir
qu'en essayant de le combattre,
il y a un reste,
un prix à payer. Précisément,
la civilisation, il y aura toujours
une insatisfaction liée
à ce point-là et je pense
qu'au-delà de la psychanalyse,
c'est un enseignement
qui va au-delà. On a parlé
de la dimension politique,
mais même dans la dimension sociale,
aujourd'hui, je vois par exemple
ce que j'appelle, si vous voulez,
la déglingue,
d'un mot un peu... familier,
c'est-à-dire
c'est pas simplement
la dimension économicosociale,
c'est aussi
une déstructuration
presque anthropologique.
Quand vous conjuguez
le chômage de masse,
l'absence de travail,
d'épreuve du réel et de sentiment
d'utilité dans la société,
avec les déstructurations
familiales,
les solidarités collectives,
je pense
qu'on a des formes
de déstructurations nouvelles,
pas simplement la pauvreté ancienne,
parce que la pauvreté ancienne,
vous pouviez gagner peu d'argent,
mais vous aviez
une forme d'estime de vous
et vous étiez
inséré dans une collectivité.
Il y avait une morale commune.
Ce qui me frappe
dans certaines émeutes,
avec des jeunes,
dans les faits divers...
-On va rentrer dans le détail.
-Juste un point.
Ca veut dire que chez les policiers,
les éducateurs,
ils disent : "On est frappés
par une chose : il n'y a pas
"de sentiment de culpabilité."
Précisément, chez Freud,
la culpabilité est liée
au phénomène civilisationnel.
-Pierre de Senarclens ?
-Je ne veux pas me faire
l'avocat des anges, mais j'aimerais
rappeler que nous avons atteint
un très haut degré de civilisation,
en particulier en Europe.
Nous avons harmonisé
nos relations,
nous avons pacifié
nos relations sociales
au point qu'effectivement,
nous ne comprenons plus
les raisons de faire la guerre.
Alors, évidemment,
cette institutionnalisation,
chacun ne la vit pas
de la même manière.
Certains se révoltent contre
cette institutionnalisation,
ces normes,
en particulier les populistes,
mais il faut admettre
que pour l'instant, notre socle
civilisationnel tient bon
et qu'il est
plus fort, plus solide,
que beaucoup
de civilisations qui nous entourent
et ça, je crois qu'on doit
en tenir compte.
-Jean-Louis,
vous êtes d'accord
pour considérer qu'aujourd'hui,
aujourd'hui, comme hier,
il y a
un déglingage anthropologique,
selon le terme
de Jean-Pierre Le Goff ?
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a beaucoup
de choses qui fichent le camp.
-Oui, mais lesquelles ?
Je veux dire, effectivement,
qu'est-ce qui a changé ?
-Est-ce que la déchristianisation,
la solitarisation des familles,
est-ce que la pression
des minorités,
est-ce que tous ces éléments...
Est-ce que le fait
que les inégalités sociales
demeurent,
malgré le progrès social,
est-ce que tout ça fait
que ça contribue
à un déglingage anthropologique,
en quelque sorte ?
-J'insiste
à nouveau sur le fait
que Freud associe...
...sa pratique privée,
c'est-à-dire
en tant que psychanalyste,
c'est-à-dire travaille théoriquement
la question de l'individuel,
de l'individu,
avec cette notion,
qu'a très bien décrit Gérard Miller,
mais...
je suis toujours pas d'accord
avec le fait de garder
le mot "pessimisme".
C'est un peu contradictoire,
d'ailleurs, parce que
vous évoquiez très bien
ce qui est structural, finalement.
Je vais pas reprendre,
mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que la pulsion de mort ?
Pourquoi Freud amène ça ?
Il l'amène à la fois
par ses analyses personnelles,
et puis, c'est vrai,
par une interrogation
sur la civilisation.
-Il observe aussi
la montée du nazisme dans la ville
où il travaillait,
la montée des intolérances.
-Mais il a aussi
une pratique individuelle.
Sans cesse,
il associe l'individuel et le...
Je veux pas dire le sociologique,
parce que ça n'est pas...
son rôle, sa fonction,
mais ce que je veux dire,
c'est que si c'est structural,
je reviens sur la contradiction,
mais si c'est structural, oui,
vous l'avez très bien dit,
et ça va complètement à l'inverse
de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui,
nous ne sommes pas si bons que ça.
Enfin, voilà,
il y a quelque chose
qui fait qu'au fond de nous-mêmes,
il y a quelque chose qui peut
s'appeler la pulsion de mort,
ou et c'est ce que l'on peut voir
aujourd'hui,
et qui va donner,
si l'on peut dire, les voix
à la pulsion de mort d'agir,
et qui est la haine.
Effectivement, est-ce qu'il y a
un pessimisme à ça ?
Probablement, oui.
Sans doute.
On peut regarder
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui.
Quand vous évoquiez le pourquoi
et les changements,
dans...
la Revue Lacanienne publiée
ces deux dernières années,
quels ont été les titres ?
"Le marché de l'identité".
Parce qu'il faut nommer
ce qui change.
L'identité, c'est quoi ?
C'est important, aujourd'hui,
cette question-là.
"Le marché de l'identité".
"Les croyances".
Ca aussi,
c'est quelque chose de fondamental.
Qu'est-ce qu'il en est de la
ou des croyances aujourd'hui ?
C'était le 2e numéro.
Le 3e numéro,
sorti il y a quelques mois,
c'est "Haines".
"Haines", au pluriel.
C'est là-dessus
que nous pouvons travailler.
Quels ont été
les changements de cela ?
Mais ce sont des...
Comment dire ?
Ce sont des thèmes qui lient
à la fois notre pratique,
et puis,
comme vous le disiez... Moi,
je dirais pas une vision du monde,
parce que Freud s'y est opposé,
mais une analyse,
une analyse des civilisations.
-Alors, haines,
identité, ce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui,
dans les dictatures totalitaires,
Etats
ou groupes terroristes,
il y a également
cette pulsion autodestructrice.
On le voit
au Proche-Orient,
notamment avec le pogrom
du 7 octobre opéré par le Hamas.
On le voit dans la guerre
avec l'Ukraine.
A votre avis...
...cette permanence...
...de la pulsion autodestructrice,
malgré
la pulsion civilisatrice,
si on peut dire,
comment vous expliquez ça,
Juliette Méadel ?
-Je le prendrais dans un sens
un peu différent et je dirais
pour quand même essayer
de garder une touche d'optimisme,
que ce combat
que mène le Hamas en Israël,
ou que mène Poutine
en envahissant l'Ukraine,
est aussi un combat
qui est dirigé
contre
un autre modèle civilisationnel,
en l'occurrence, le nôtre.
Le nôtre, qui comporte
ses propres pulsions
d'autodestruction,
vise quand même
à une forme d'apaisement
dans les relations sociales.
Je ne partage pas l'idée
d'un même stade relationnel
les uns avec les autres,
que ce que
nous avons vécu en 1929 ou même,
après la 2e Guerre mondiale.
Je crois profondément qu'il y a
un progrès aujourd'hui,
y compris pensé par le politique,
dans ne serait-ce
que l'accompagnement social.
Il y a des ambitions aujourd'hui
données par les gouvernements
en Europe en général.
Prenons la France.
On est quand même
dans un modèle où aujourd'hui
on s'intéresse aux victimes.
C'est l'ancienne secrétaire d'Etat
à l'Aide aux victimes qui parle,
mais quand François Hollande crée
et met en place la politique d'aide
aux victimes, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
-Pendant la présidence
de François Hollande,
on a eu Charlie Hebdo,
on a eu les attentats
de l'Hyper Cacher, etc.
-Parce que précisément,
c'est des attentats qui sont dirigés
contre un autre modèle de société,
le nôtre,
qui est un modèle qui repose
sur l'égalité,
la liberté, la fraternité,
sur la non-agression,
sur la non-violence, sur le recours
par l'Etat à la violence
uniquement dans un cadre légal,
sur l'intervention du juge,
sur un hôpital qui soigne
même quand on est
en situation irrégulière,
sur un droit au logement.
Evidemment,
c'est loin d'être parfait,
mais ça,
ça forge quoi ?
Ca forge quand même
un projet de société
qui est infiniment
moins violent et moins contraignant
du point de vue...
et qui a vocation
à brider les pulsions.
Le nôtre.
Ca forge quand même
les bases
d'un modèle de société qui,
à mon sens,
est bien plus enviable
que ce que nous pouvons trouver
dans un Etat totalitaire.
-Gérard Miller ?
-Je suis presque
d'accord avec vous.
-Incroyable !
-Presque. Je vais,
si vous le permettez,
le formuler en freudien,
c'est-à-dire,
lorsqu'on est freudien acquis,
finalement, la surprise,
ce ne soit pas
que des gens se retrouvant
s'entretuent. La surprise,
c'est de savoir pourquoi
ils ne s'entretuent pas.
D'une certaine façon,
je considère que
nous ne sommes pas moins sauvages
qu'on l'était au Moyen Age
ou sous Jésus-Christ,
mais quelque chose a progressé
et il faut le protéger
comme la prunelle de nos yeux :
ce que Lacan appelle "symbolique".
Pourquoi on ne s'entretue pas ?
Parce qu'il y a entre nous
quelque chose qui s'échange.
L'homme ne progresse pas,
mais les institutions
dont il se dote le protègent.
De ce point de vue-là,
je dirai que collectivement,
les hommes se rendent compte de ça.
C'est pour ça
que c'est précieux
de ne pas toucher
aux signifiants que nous échangeons.
Quand je vois comme on parle
d'êtres humains,
les étrangers,
et pas seulement
les migrants clandestins,
je me dis que c'est
du plus grand danger.
Quand on commence
à parler d'êtres humains
de cette façon,
on met en danger
l'ensemble de la société,
la symbolique qui me permet
de vous considérer en semblable
ou de considérer celui
qui n'a pas ma couleur
ou ma religion
comme mon semblable.
Les hommes ne progressent pas,
mais les institutions
dont ils se dotent
et qui sont précieuses,
progressent.
Vous avez raison de dire
que nous ne sommes pas
dans les mêmes systèmes
que dans les dictatures
et non plus comme au Moyen Age.
C'est pour ça qu'il faut faire
très attention.
C'est en ce sens
que l'extrême droite
est extrêmement dangereuse,
car elle remet en question
les signifiants,
le symbolique
qui nous permet de coexister.
-Vous vouliez réagir. Je donne
la parole à Jean-Pierre Le Goff.
-Sur la démocratie, il ne s'agit pas
de confondre le totalitarisme
et la démocratie. Cela étant dit,
il y a des aspects aussi
de faiblesses internes
aux démocraties,
et notamment une forme
de mésestime de soi,
d'une certaine façon,
et une forme de culpabilité
qui peut devenir très malsaine.
C'est-à-dire, en gros,
nos sociétés seraient
responsables quasiment
de tous les maux
et une grande difficulté...
-Je vais vous donner
la parole.
-Une difficulté
à admettre
qu'on puisse avoir des ennemis
qui veulent nous détruire.
Je pense qu'il y a
une perte d'estime de soi
au sein même des démocraties
par rapport
aux ressources
que constitue notre histoire,
notamment les Lumières,
et une grande difficulté
à assumer ça.
En face, vous avez des gens
qui vous disent : "Nous, la mort,
il n'y a pas de problème."
-Jean-Pierre Le Goff,
précisez :
est-ce que dans ce déglingage
que vous observez,
vous y mettez
la déchristianisation,
la perte des valeurs
des Lumières,
quelque chose que l'Occident
aurait oublié de son passé ?
-Oui, oui,
mais il y a des ressources,
ce que j'appelle
des réserves d'humanité qui sont là,
qui vont combattre quelque chose
d'irréductible et qui revient.
Le problème, c'est l'état
des ressources internes
des démocraties européennes,
par rapport à leur histoire
et la façon
dont elles se pensent
et du rôle qu'elles ont à jouer.
Il y a un point de faiblesse
face à des ennemis
évidemment totalitaires,
qui n'ont aucun problème.
Eux : "On est prêts à mourir,
"on ne craint pas la mort."
C'était le discours des terroristes.
"Pourquoi on va vous vaincre ?
Parce que vous aimez la vie."
C'est extraordinaire,
quand vous écoutez ça.
Je pense
qu'il y a une faiblesse interne
à reconnaître qu'on a des ennemis.
Ca veut dire que des gens
veulent nous détruire.
Il faut combattre.
Ce n'est pas simplement
la non-violence.
-Je donne la parole
à Jean-Louis Chassaing sur ce point.
-Je reviendrai sur cette question,
sur ce mot de "déglingage",
par rapport à ce que vous disiez
de la déchristianisation.
J'insistais tout à l'heure
sur la question des croyances.
-Ce n'est pas la même chose.
-Non, mais...
-Les sectes
et les religions,
ce n'est pas pareil.
-Qu'est-ce qu'il en est,
aujourd'hui ?
Est-ce que, justement,
les sectes ne prolifèrent pas ?
Et de quelle religion s'agit-il ?
Parce que le déglingage, moi,
je l'entends comme, par exemple,
le titre de la revue, c'est :
"Qu'est-ce que vous croyez ?"
C'est effectivement
la multiplication des croyances
de tout un chacun.
Aujourd'hui, on a pu le voir,
vous parliez tout à l'heure
de la Covid.
On a vu, effectivement,
que les sciences,
la politique étaient quotidiennement
et pratiquement remises en question
par le fait que chacun a
sa croyance concernant
cette pathologie.
Et ça, c'était quand même
quelque chose
qui était délicat et difficile.
Moi, j'étais très intéressé
par ce...
par ce duo scientifiques/politiques.
Je relisais donc Yersin,
qui était un médecin
qui a découvert
le bacille de la peste
et qui, à un moment donné, dit :
"J'ai découvert ça. C'est très bien.
"J'ai fait un vaccin,
j'ai découvert la bactérie.
"J'ai fait un vaccin. OK."
Deux ans plus tard, rebelote,
il y a à nouveau une peste.
On appelle Yersin.
Il dit : "Attendez, je suis désolé.
Moi, j'ai découvert la bactérie
"et le vaccin. Aux politiques
d'aller voir pourquoi
"il y a à nouveau
quelque chose qui revient."
Sur le plan du citoyen,
cette question
n'intéressait personne.
Chacun avait sa croyance.
Je reviens...
Il y a beaucoup de choses
sur cette question...
-Pas trop.
-L'autodestruction.
Pourquoi ? La pulsion de mort,
c'est pas une autodestruction.
La pulsion de mort,
c'est la pulsion de mort.
Et donc, Freud a repris ça un peu
à Sabina Spielrein,
qui, elle, parlait de destruction.
C'est pas la même chose.
C'est pas une autodestruction
non plus. La pulsion de mort,
c'est quelque chose qui vient
dans un au-delà
du principe du plaisir,
que Lacan a pu appeler
la jouissance,
et qui est quelque chose...
C'est une autre pulsion.
Elle n'est pas forcément
autodestructrice au départ.
-Oui.
Pierre de Senarclens ?
-Je crois qu'il y a un texte
de Freud tout à fait remarquable,
c'est celui qu'il écrit
en 1915, lorsqu'il réfléchit
sur l'effondrement
de ce que l'on peut appeler alors
la civilisation européenne,
et il met en évidence
l'extraordinaire fragilité
de nos civilisations,
et en particulier
de nos mécanismes
institutionnels
qui visent à contenir
ou à endiguer les pulsions.
Et dans ce texte,
on sent une nostalgie
d'un monde d'avant-guerre,
qui s'est effondré
et qui s'est effondré aussi
pas seulement
parce que les individus
voulaient réaliser leurs pulsions,
mais parce que
les institutions contenaient
une énorme agressivité,
qui a été mobilisée
par les gouvernements.
Mais ça nous renvoie aussi au fait
qu'au temps de Freud,
les contraintes surmoïques étaient
quand même beaucoup plus fortes
que de nos jours,
n'est-ce pas ?
Aujourd'hui, on vit dans un monde
où ces contraintes
se sont en partie évaporées.
Nous n'avons plus
de contraintes religieuses,
en n'oubliant pas que Freud pensait
que la religion
chrétienne était une névrose
de contrainte de l'humanité,
mais enfin, je passe là-dessus.
Mais on n'a plus
ces croyances structurantes,
on n'a plus de modèle d'autorité
et on a...
On est dans une société sans père,
une société
où les enfants sont élevés
très longtemps sans contraintes
et cette absence
de contraintes suscite,
dans une société de désir,
une société
où on réalise nos désirs,
et ces sociétés créent aussi
énormément de frustration.
Cette frustration est liée
à tout ce qui entrave les désirs,
n'est-ce pas ?
Et on a aujourd'hui
beaucoup de peine à accepter
des modèles d'autorité,
hiérarchiques,
qui nous permettraient
d'assumer un idéal du moi qui soit
à peu près stable et constant.
Et la conséquence,
c'est son repli
sur des groupes,
sur des sectes,
sur des petites organisations
qui ont de la peine
à collaborer et à faire
communauté ensemble.
-On s'aperçoit que Freud,
à travers cette citation,
dans "Malaise dans la civilisation",
c'est très net, Freud se méfiait
de l'idéologie révolutionnaire,
comme de toutes les idéologies.
D'ailleurs,
il a refusé de prendre parti
sur des causes politiques,
que son ami Adler proposait.
Est-ce que sa méfiance
vis-à-vis des idéologies,
qui ont pour finalité
la pulsion de mort,
parfois camouflée
en bien de l'humanité,
est-ce qu'à votre avis,
au regard des conflits sanglants
d'aujourd'hui,
qui ont pour marques idéologiques
le communisme,
le fascisme, l'islamisme,
que Semprun, Jorge Semprun,
l'écrivain,
considérait
comme un totalitarisme vert,
est-ce qu'il avait raison
d'avoir cette méfiance
idéologique ? Gérard Miller,
je vous regarde,
pas avec une intention prononcée,
mais j'aimerais
avoir votre avis là-dessus.
-D'abord,
il faut préciser
que le moins qu'on puisse dire,
c'est que Freud n'était pas
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
un homme de gauche,
encore moins révolutionnaire.
Il s'intéressait peu
à la politique.
-Jacques Lacan était
dans cette même position.
-Lacan...
-Votre frère l'a dit
dans une émission ici.
-Lacan votait, je crois,
pour de Gaulle.
Non, mais c'est important.
Mis à part l'intérêt prononcé
qu'il avait pour la question juive,
pour les persécutions,
Freud n'était pas un politique.
Ca ne l'a pas empêché d'écrire
des textes justes,
comme "Psychologie collective
et analyse du moi".
Vous me permettrez
d'ajouter à votre liste,
le colonialisme,
l'impérialisme,
c'est-à-dire
toutes sortes d'autres...
-Absolument.
-...méfaits.
-J'accepte.
-Qui ne se réduisent pas
à ce que la gauche a produit
de terrible.
-J'accepte ces ajouts.
-C'est sûr que...
Je citais "Psychologie collective
et analyse du moi",
très beau texte de Freud,
notamment sur la montée du fascisme,
et qui montre à quel point...
On s'intéressait au collectif,
à quel point ceux qui vivent
collectivement ont besoin
d'un rapport vertical.
C'est le rapport au chef,
le rapport à une idéologie.
De ce point de vue-là,
permettez-moi de dire
que le psychanalyste que je suis
ne croit pas que la religion
ait joué un rôle pacificateur,
même si à certains moments,
c'était utile.
Le vrai problème,
si vous voulez,
on l'a évoqué
à un moment à propos
de la guerre en Yougoslavie.
Qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé dans la guerre ?
Vous aviez
un certain nombre de peuples...
-Vous parlez de 99,
du Kosovo ?
Avant, même ?
-Des peuples cohabitaient,
tant bien que mal,
sous le titisme et on avait fabriqué
cette entité bizarroïde,
la Yougoslavie,
avec des gens qui n'avaient
pas la même langue.
On a créé une langue,
qu'on a essayé d'imposer.
Croates, Bosniaques,
musulmans arrivaient
à cohabiter,
avec des éléments communs.
Ils s'échangeaient des choses,
dont notamment
la référence au pays.
Lorsque le symbolique a cédé,
le frère a tué le frère.
On a vu des gens...
Je me souviens,
professeur à l'université,
d'étudiants bosniaques disant :
"Lorsqu'on était jeunes,
"jamais on se demandait
si le voisin..."
-La religion a émergé.
-Parce que d'un coup,
le peu de symbolique
qu'il y avait,
et je ne vante pas le titisme,
évidemment,
mais le symbolique qui permettait
de cohabiter ayant cédé,
c'est le pire qui remontait,
notamment les communautarismes,
les groupes haineux,
les religieux.
C'est de ce point de vue-là,
si vous voulez, qu'il faut revenir
à cette idée essentielle :
trouvons les signifiants
qui nous permettent de cohabiter
les uns avec les autres.
Chaque fois que ces signifiants
sont en jeu, le pire est là,
que ce soit
le stalinisme,
que ce soit la dictature
hitlérienne. A chaque fois, c'est...
Comment le dire mieux ?
-Vous mettriez l'islamisme
aujourd'hui au même niveau ?
C'est ce que déjà
Semprun disait
dans les années 60,
que c'était un totalitarisme vert ?
-Ecoutez,
je ne sais pas s'il faut
le qualifier de totalitarisme,
mais ce qu'on appelle
l'islamisme aujourd'hui
est une monstruosité absolue qui...
Si vous voulez,
c'est pour ça
que je suis gêné quand on dit :
"Est-ce que c'est le fascisme ?"
Tout s'inscrit
grosso modo dans la même eau.
On voit bien...
Vous évoquiez le Hamas
et le 7 octobre,
mais il y a beaucoup d'autres
exemples, malheureusement.
On voit, en effet,
des manifestations de violence
terroriste, dictatoriale,
fascisante de la même eau.
Je suis d'accord
pour qu'on fasse des distinctions.
C'est la même chose.
-Justement,
sur ces idéologies meurtrières ?
-Oui,
c'est des idéologies meurtrières.
Par rapport
à ce qui a été dit, je pense
qu'on assiste en France à des formes
de désinstitutionnalisation.
Je vais prendre un exemple
très concret : le harcèlement moral.
Je me suis intéressé à cette notion,
qui est apparue vers les années 90.
Le schéma qui domine aujourd'hui
dans le débat public,
c'est la victime,
et je dirais, un duel...
Une relation duelle
entre une pure victime
et un pur salaud,
avec des phénomènes de lapidation
à travers les médias.
Et ça, je pense...
Vous parliez des démocraties
et ce qui...
Il y a une victimologie qui,
à mon avis,
est significative
de cette désinstitutionnalisation.
On prend le travail,
par exemple.
Vous avez des conflits du travail,
qui étaient envisagés
sous une dimension collective.
Vous étiez à l'intérieur
d'un collectif
et ce n'était pas simplement
votre subjectivité.
Quand vous vous heurtiez
au petit chef,
c'était pas simplement
"moi, individu,
"avec mon élément particulier
"face à un pervers". C'était "moi,
participant d'un collectif",
qui était le monde ouvrier,
la classe ouvrière,
"face à quelqu'un
"qui représentait le capitalisme".
Là,
on a tous ces...
Comme si
les oripeaux institutionnels,
j'emploie le mot "oripeaux"
entre guillemets, avaient sauté.
A ce moment-là, vous avez
ces affects et ces rencontres
de subjectivité à subjectivité qui,
à mon avis,
sont hautement problématiques.
Je pense, sans résumer
l'état des démocraties à cela,
que c'est une faiblesse
interne de la démocratie.
Quand les politiques encouragent
cette dimension,
ils ne savent pas ce qu'ils font.
-Oui,
Juliette Méadel ?
-Je ne partage pas du tout
ce que vous dites.
-Je me doute.
-Non pas que je considère que...
faire du particulier
le représentant de l'universel
soit forcément une solution,
mais je pense, au contraire,
que ce que nous avons vécu,
prenons par exemple MeToo.
Je vais pas vous parler
des victimes d'attentats,
mais de MeToo,
c'est quand même aussi
dans la société de communication
que nous avons aujourd'hui
une manière
d'attirer davantage
l'attention du grand public
sur une histoire qui raconte
un conflit de pouvoir.
L'hypothèse de la jeune pupille
d'un parrain qui abuse d'elle
sexuellement ou du patron,
par exemple, Georges Tron,
qui abuse de son employée
sur le plan sexuel, c'est un rapport
de pouvoir qui s'exerce
en l'écrasante défaveur
de la victime.
Sur le plan effectivement médiatique
ou cinématographique,
ou même sur le plan du récit,
quand on attire l'attention
sur un cas,
ça n'est jamais, en fait,
que la mise en mouvement
d'un conflit institutionnel,
l'institutionnel écrasant
étant le patron,
l'homme blanc,
de plus de 60 ans, contre... Oui.
Mais je vais vous dire,
c'est une réalité
quantitative. C'est-à-dire
que quand la démocratie
aujourd'hui s'enrichit
de la défense des victimes,
c'est juste le rétablissement
d'une injustice
qui perdure depuis
la nuit des temps.
Je ne considère absolument pas,
et c'est une logique
qu'on peut appliquer
au droit du travail,
car le cas
du harcèlement moral au travail
est le même :
des cas difficiles à qualifier
sur le plan judiciaire et juridique,
car la preuve des faits commis
et de l'absence
de consentement dans le cas
du harcèlement sexuel
au travail est difficile
à rapporter.
Donc, 99 % des victimes
de viols au travail...
-Revenons à Freud,
si vous voulez bien.
-Et donc, revenons à Freud,
la question institutionnelle
se pose pour dire
que ça n'entrave pas
le bon fonctionnement
de la démocratie.
-Vous êtes en désaccord.
Pourquoi pas ? On a le droit.
-Ca ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y ait pas des victimes,
qui...
-Ca fait régresser la démocratie
de défendre
les victimes ?
-Non, ce que je veux dire,
c'est que c'est différent
de la psychanalyse.
La psychanalyse, dans le rapport
entre le pervers et la victime,
suppose des mécanismes inconscients
dans lesquels les deux participent.
C'est effacé au profit
d'un comportementaliste,
où on repère les bons
et mauvais comportements.
Ca ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y ait pas de victimes,
mais le schéma comportementaliste
entre le pervers
et sa victime est quelque chose
qui a mis en question un des aspects
de la psychanalyse
qui me paraît essentiel,
c'est qu'il y a une autre scène
par rapport à cette scène manifeste.
Cette scène est plus compliquée.
C'est tout.
A partir de là, il y a la loi.
-Si vous voulez...
On a beaucoup de questions.
-Je suis d'accord sur le fait...
Ca, c'est le champ
de la psychanalyse,
la victime n'est pas
complètement victime.
-On vous a entendue,
Juliette Méadel, on vous a entendue.
Je vais donner
la parole à Pierre.
-Je vais revenir sur quelque chose
qui devrait nous préoccuper,
c'est ce problème,
notre difficulté
à résister aux frustrations.
Lorsqu'on a aujourd'hui
un homme politique,
qui a été président des Etats-Unis
et qui risque
de le redevenir,
et qui s'est permis
dans sa carrière politique
de dire tout et n'importe quoi,
d'avoir affirmé
qu'il pouvait descendre
dans la 5e Avenue,
de tuer quelqu'un et d'être
réélu, d'avoir humilié...
-Vous parlez de Donald Trump.
-Je parle de Donald Trump.
Je ne parle pas de Donald Trump,
je parle d'une foule de gens
qui se sont suffisamment
identifiés à ce voyou
pour accepter de voter pour lui.
Je crois que c'est un grand problème
d'expliquer
pourquoi aujourd'hui
tant de gens s'identifient
à un personnage
de cette nature. Parce que
l'élection est un choix identitaire.
-Une vraie bonne question.
-Dans la question
des Etats-Unis, dans la question
du populisme en Europe,
on s'aperçoit que les idées
qui gouvernent les populistes sont
fragiles. Il n'y a pas d'idéologie.
Il y a des comportements :
des comportements iconoclastes,
des comportements de voyous,
des comportements
et des idées qui sont
très incohérentes,
mais qui visent en quelque sorte
à détruire les procédures
et les institutions. Pourquoi est-ce
qu'on s'identifie à ces gens ?
Cette question nous intéresse.
-Jean-Louis Chassaing,
je voudrais, sur ce point,
avoir votre avis.
J'ai lu Freud.
J'ai même publié un livre là-dessus.
Comment vous expliquez
que Freud en 36, 37, 38,
il appréhendait
la violence du nazisme ?
Il en a même été victime.
Mais il pensait, il pensait
que les institutions
tiendraient
et qu'on n'arriverait pas
à cette catastrophe.
Est-ce que de sa part,
à votre avis,
c'était de la naïveté
et que tout allait
être emporté ?
Ou est-ce qu'il pensait
que la civilisation des Lumières,
à laquelle il appartenait,
ferait digue face à cette...
que vous le vouliez ou pas,
cette pulsion
exterminatrice
qui a contribué à la Shoah ?
-Justement, pendant ces années
que vous évoquez,
il a écrit ces textes,
"Anthropologie de la psychanalyse".
Et donc effectivement, il...
Il avait cette...
Il avait cette inquiétude,
de savoir ce qui se passait
dans les civilisations
après 1920,
après avoir découvert
et posé la question
de la pulsion de mort.
-Mais sa santé était en jeu
dans les années 30.
Il a été sauvé miraculeusement
grâce à un concours diplomatique
international, qui mêle
l'ambassadeur des Etats-Unis,
la princesse Bonaparte, etc.
-Je crois que...
-Les digues...
-Ca ne concerne pas essentiellement
les civilisations,
mais il y a cette relation
assez modérée de Freud
à la politique,
et il était assez prudent
par rapport à ça.
Autant il a pu être osé
dans ses descriptions
des civilisations et puis,
il a eu des appuis politiques aussi.
Il y a eu un moment
où il a été expert
contre un de ses amis
après la guerre et où il a eu
des appuis politiques
qui étaient très importants,
mais... On lui demandait...
Easterman, par exemple,
lui a demandé : "Et vous ?",
parce qu'on insistait sur ça.
C'est une insistance
sur sa position.
"Qu'êtes-vous politiquement ?"
Réponse de Freud :
"Politiquement, je ne suis rien."
Bon, je veux dire...
-Les textes
sont politiques.
le sont.
On lui demandait.
Oui, mais attendez...
On lui demandait, en insistant :
"Oui, mais quand même,
quelle est votre couleur ?
"Ni rouge, ni blanc."
"Quelle est votre couleur ?"
Réponse de Freud,
réponse d'analyste.
Réponse de Freud :
"Je suis couleur chair."
C-H-A-I-R.
C'était tout à fait surprenant,
c'est-à-dire
couleur de l'homme
et pas de la peau,
mais aussi, ajoutait-il,
"sans pour autant aller à fond
du côté d'un humanisme."
Donc voilà,
par rapport à la question
de la politique, le seul engagement
qu'il a pu avoir,
c'était par rapport à quelque chose
qui ne s'est pas fait
et qui était un ordre international
de la culture et de l'éthique,
et il demandait à ce que ce soit
à la Société des Nations.
Et ça ne s'est pas fait.
Je voudrais revenir sur la question
que vous évoquiez, de Donald Trump.
C'est une interrogation,
mais justement,
ce qu'a dit Gérard Miller,
et ce pour quoi je plaide aussi
en tant qu'analyste,
moi, ça ne me surprend pas du tout
qu'on puisse
voter pour un homme comme ça.
L'homme n'est pas seulement bon
et je dirais même
que Trump soit accusé
et qu'il se défende
et qu'il se batte pour ça,
ça peut, au contraire,
augmenter son charisme,
si on peut dire.
-Je vous fais
réagir sur une dernière question
qui concerne la France.
La France a connu
beaucoup de révolutions
ou d'épisodes révolutionnaires.
1789-1793.
1848, La Commune,
mai 68, les gilets jaunes.
Au regard de ce qu'il en est
sorti,
est-ce qu'à votre avis,
on pouvait éviter
les débordements violents ?
Est-ce qu'il est possible
de s'opposer
à une fatalité révolutionnaire ?
Freud disait : "Il n'y a pas
de révolutionnaire qu'un autre,
"plus radical, ne supplante."
Autrement dit,
et plus trivialement,
chassez le naturel, c'est-à-dire
les pulsions psychiques primitives,
il revient au galop.
Est-ce que vous pensez que...
Finalement,
on revient à la question du début :
est-ce qu'il y a cette fatalité
révolutionnaire qui engendre
toujours des violences ?
-Il faut voir ce qu'on entend
par "révolution".
C'est-à-dire si on entend
une rupture radicale,
parce que c'était ça
qui était en question,
on peut dire qu'à partir de là,
il y a une logique
qui est enclenchée entre 89 et 93.
C'est pas tout à fait la même chose,
mais il y a déjà des germes en 89
qui vont jusqu'à 93.
Il y a deux lectures possibles :
ou c'est deux moments différents
de la Révolution ou on pense
qu'il y avait des germes dès 89,
mais il est clair
que la notion de révolution
en ce qu'elle implique
une rupture radicale
et qui était souvent accompagnée
d'un homme nouveau,
ça allait un peu de pair,
oui, effectivement,
si vous raisonnez dans ce cadre-là,
oui,
les révolutionnaires finissent
par s'autodévorer entre eux,
c'est-à-dire
qu'eux-mêmes se liquident
entre eux,
donc il y a ce mécanisme,
une fois enclenché qui peut
aller loin. En ce sens-là, oui.
Je dirais oui par rapport
à votre question.
-Sur cette fatalité.
-C'est drôle,
que vous aligniez
ces moments glorieux
de l'histoire française,
de la révolution de 89...
-Que je ne conteste pas.
-Non, mais vous les alignez
avec le terme de "fatalité".
Moi, je mettrais ça
du côté de la chance.
Ces moments-là,
qui ne se terminent pas tous
très bien,
et notamment pour
les révolutionnaires,
sont au contraire des moments
où quelque chose de l'humain va
du côté de l'idéal,
va du côté du positif.
-La question
qui vous est posée, Gérard Miller,
comme aux autres, était :
"Il n'y a pas de révolutionnaire
"qu'un autre, plus radical,
ne supplante." Vous êtes d'accord
avec cette phrase-là ?
-Pourquoi l'ancien gauchiste
que je suis considère
que la révolution
doit être citoyenne
et plus violente ?
Jeune, je pensais
que la violence,
on va dire ça,
était accoucheuse de l'histoire.
On s'est aperçu quand même,
à un moment donné,
que la violence révolutionnaire
jouait non seulement contre
les méchants
et les supposés gentils,
qu'elle se retournait,
en effet.
Je n'inviterai personne,
dont les gilets jaunes
que j'ai soutenus,
à envoyer un pavé,
ce que dans ma jeunesse
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire.
Vous avez raison,
il est temps pour ceux qui,
comme moi, veulent changer le monde,
de comprendre que ce n'est pas
par la violence qu'on y arrivera.
-Qu'est-ce qui retient votre bras
d'envoyer un pavé ?
-Ce qui le retient...
-L'âge ? La sagesse ?
-Outre la responsabilité d'enfants
et de petits-enfants,
c'est le fait que j'ai compris,
à un moment donné, mieux vaut tard
que jamais, que la violence
n'accouchait pas du meilleur.
En effet, ce que l'histoire
des révolutionnaires montre,
c'est à quel point
la violence révolutionnaire
est détournée de ses objectifs,
on va dire,
et de ses idéaux.
-Pour répondre à la question
que vous avez posée sur Freud
et les révolutionnaires
qui sont dépassés,
c'est qu'ils imaginaient
que le révolutionnaire était
une lutte contre le père,
que ça s'institutionnalisait
et qu'il y avait des enfants
qui allaient ensuite
détruire l'institutionnalisation
issue du monde révolutionnaire.
La problématique française,
il faut la comparer
à ce qui s'est passé
dans les pays d'origine protestante,
qui n'ont pas eu ce même rapport
à la violence et à la terreur.
-Pour vous,
Jean-Louis Chassaing,
révolution engendre
révolution,
radicalité engendre radicalité ?
C'est notre point de conclusion.
-Je ne saurais pas répondre
à votre question.
-C'est le point de la conclusion.
-Je reviendrai à Freud. Vous parliez
tout à l'heure de la Russie.
Dans ce texte
sur la vision du monde,
Freud reparle un peu comme ça
de la révolution et dit :
"C'est pas mal, il y a quelque chose
"qui s'est fait,
il y a un événement."
Puis, à un moment donné, il dit :
"On va voir."
-Oui, mais il a quand même
condamné dans le texte
très clairement.
Juliette Méadel ?
-L'enjeu n'est pas
pour l'avenir de la France,
la révolution,
mais notre capacité à être radicaux
et peut-être violents,
dans la réponse à apporter
aux assauts des régimes totalitaires
de l'extérieur, mais également
des poussées de l'extrême droite.
Et donc, il faut que nous soyons
radicaux pour préserver...
-Sincèrement,
Juliette Méadel,
l'antisémitisme aujourd'hui
est de nature de l'extrême droite
ou de l'extrême gauche ?
Répondez-moi là-dessus.
-Les deux, mon général.
Je ne crois pas du tout que Le Pen
et que la famille Le Pen
ou que le Rassemblement national
protégera davantage les Juifs.
-Personne ne vous a posé
la question.
-Je les renvoie dos à dos.
Je crois que
toute forme d'idéologie extrémiste
portée par l'un
ou l'autre des camps,
est à proscrire
et qu'il faut donc être radicaux
pour préserver la liberté,
l'égalité et la fraternité.
Radicaux, ça veut peut-être dire
que la faiblesse des démocraties,
pour rebondir sur vos propos,
c'est de ne pas croire assez
en leur propre force
et en leur propre modèle de liberté
et d'égalité
et de fraternité.
-Je voudrais vous présenter
une brève bibliographie.
Pour ceux que Freud intéresse,
les oeuvres complètes
ont paru aux Presses Universitaires
de France.
Donc, vous pourrez lire
tout ce que Freud a écrit.
Jean-Pierre Le Goff,
vous publiez "Mes années folles".
En un mot, vous regrettez
ces années folles,
quand vous étiez
un révolutionnaire.
Vous biffez ça d'un trait à la fin,
en disant : "J'ai été naïf."
-Non, non, je pense que...
Ce que j'ai découvert
en retravaillant les textes,
c'est l'articulation
entre une certaine forme d'idéologie
avec des affects et des passions,
et y compris adolescentes.
C'est pas simplement
une histoire intellectualiste,
c'est pas simplement
un rapport au texte.
-Donc, vous comprenez...
-Ca met en jeu des passions,
y compris
des passions problématiques,
si vous voulez.
-Vous comprenez
que les gens veuillent rester
dans cette durée adolescente.
-Je pense que c'est arrêt sur image
et à un moment,
l'épreuve du réel finit
par vous rattraper. J'espère.
-Pierre de Senarclens,
vous publiez
un livre sur nos questions :
"Nation et nationalismes",
aux éditions Sciences Humaines.
Vous en préparez un nouveau.
Vous pensez
que le nationalisme
est de tous les temps ?
Les nationalismes.
-Les nationalismes,
je pense qu'ils s'estompent,
mais ils prennent
d'autres formes.
Lorsque l'on dit que la droite
populiste est nationaliste,
je ne suis pas tellement sûr
qu'elle l'est dans la mesure
où elle a gardé du nationalisme
la haine des étrangers,
la xénophobie et toutes sortes
de choses de ce genre-là,
mais elle collabore volontiers
avec des régimes étrangers
pour avancer sa propre cause.
L'idée nationale s'est un peu
estompée dans cet univers-là,
et l'évanescence
de l'idée nationale,
c'est aussi l'évanescence
d'un lien communautaire
de solidarité qu'on peine
à recréer aujourd'hui.
-Merci. Vous préparez
quelque chose, Gérard Miller ?
-Je prépare
un nouveau film,
qui n'est pas si éloigné
de notre discussion,
qui s'appelle "Comment pouvait-on
être maoïste en France ?",
sur un mouvement,
la Gauche prolétarienne,
qui explique
ce qui semble une aberration
que des êtres,
pas complètement cons comme nous,
ont pu être maoïstes.
Je l'explique.
-Juliette Méadel, un livre
que vous préparez ?
Ou un livre...
-Une réflexion.
Un livre fait,
"Un impérieux besoin d'agir",
où je consacre deux chapitres
à la question de la nation
et de la gauche,
car je crois profondément
au projet de la nation
d'Ernest Renan,
qui n'est pas la nation
du mauvais nationalisme,
mais est celui qui propose
un récit collectif d'intégration,
de liberté.
C'est précisément l'un des combats
qu'il faut mener.
-Je vous remercie, madame.
Merci, messieurs,
d'avoir participé
à cette émission.
Je remercie l'équipe de LCP.
Avant de nous quitter,
je vous soumets
cette citation de Freud :
"Les passions pulsionnelles
sont plus fortes
"que les intérêts rationnels."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA